ben je voudrais tomber sur une jeune
fille qui soit dans mes hanches
qu'elle soit bonne ménagée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de vous marier venez voir ce panneau
panneau qui est installé je vous
rappelle après
des grands hôtels ici à véziers un
panneau sur laquelle vous pourrez
répondre à une annonce bien que tout
simplement en assérant l'insérer une
balade
parce que s'il y en a pas pour le chien
je peux pas prendre pour moi toute seule
pour qu'on soit d'accord tous les deux
il faut encore qu'on lui trouve une
femme vous voyez une polonaise parce
qu'elle sait pas un petit français je
cherche
bel homme
[Musique]
allure mâle blonde
vous allez marquer votre annonce mon
numéro 53
votre âge 24 ans 24 ans
[Applaudissements]
pour l'emmener faire un petit tour au
ciné j'ai pas inventé le numéro 53 je
veux parler tout seul je mange tout seul
je vis tout seul je me fais du tilleul
et je m'endors dans un linceul c'est
surement pour ça que je fais la gueule
seul je me suis rendu à pied
ça fait 10 km d'aller Airtour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais tomber sur une jeune fille
qui soit dans mes orages
[Musique]
de ma vie nous avons beaucoup de
visiteurs qui viennent à veselise pour
se marier
les précédentes années nous avons eu
davantage de visiteurs mais je crois
devoir dire aussi que certains pensaient
trouver à Vezelise la solution miracle à
leurs problèmes parce que le célibat
c'est aussi un problème pour beaucoup
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer une une
femme charmante à cette fois cette
dernière fois au célibataire j'espère
que pour moi ça marchera
un peu de poil sur la poitrine mais ça
ne fait rien
je te donne celui-là
réalisé en flamme on veut être un
mariage riche et heureux alors il se
plie car au jeu
[Musique]
pour 60 ans
il a l'autre absolu pour la vie présente
la Foire des célibataires a commencé
depuis hier nous allons continuer les
festivités pour cette nuit du baiser
alors je vais demander quatre coupes sur
scène pour le jeu du plus grand baiser
[Musique]
on va lancer le big bisous big bisous en
anglais ça veut dire gros PC quand je
vous le dirai donnez-vous à baiser
moelleux à l'endroit que je vous
expliquerai
attention sur la bouche embrassez-vous
[Musique]
encore encore encore encore encore
encore encore encore encore voici donc
le prix pour le jeu du plus long baiser
une poupée gonflable c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti c'est pas tout vous énervez
pas le matin il va falloir qu'il se lave
c'est parti et c'est Michel qui commence
[Rires]
on repasse le flambeau c'est au bonhomme
c'est reparti allez vas-y Bertrand et on
a quoi
[Musique]
non je serais pas jalouse de la poupée
gonflable je crois pas
[Musique]
le même bois je suis ce qu'il aime que
le femme à la fois la femme idéale pour
moi c'est une femme gentille agréable
sache bien cuisiner et s'occuper des
enfants
je suis pas le client Monsieur le Maire
dieu merci je suis un célibataire
endurci je suis célibataire oh oui et
puis je n'ai jamais regretté une femme
mariée un petit chouillette de temps en
temps quand même un petit peu quoi j'ai
perdu ma virginité accidentellement mes
enfants
je ne regarde pas
ça je trouve c'est une trouvaille
j'avais faites pas d'accord mademoiselle
et la vie célibataire c'est assez
tranquille on l'a pas de souci
je veux bien aux alentours de chez moi
j'entends oh je me suis appelé je suis
celui-ci a fait cela en tout cas moi
puis mon voisin de Lille a pas de lit
mais enfin de maison et bien ils s'en
trouvent bien aussi lui n'est pas marié
non plus et il s'en trouve bien oh oui
[Musique]